[Musique]
françois françois pien casimir et ben je
croyais que tu fais pas aujourd'hui
parce que tu as ranger ta maison et son
jardin
on le sait vraiment je crois que je vais
avoir besoin de votre aide
c'est vrai et les enfants vous venez
casimir a besoin de nous rené venez on
se met par ici alors casimir
tu veux qu'on ait aidé mon nom j'ai déjà
même maman mon oncle upa cousine ursule
ma anatole mon oncle ma cousine gertrude
le gouvernement
ma soeur mégalomanie mon autre coup
d'arrêt de l'art et arrêta arrête arrête
casimir on a compris
tu n'as pas besoin de nous là bas non
alors dit nous quand même explique-nous
bon voilà il y à des objets j'espère que
nous avons partout et je ne sais pas
lesquels vont à l'intérieur de la maison
c'est ce qu'il en reste est dans le
jardin c'est ça ton problème
ouais et alors eh ben on va t'aider on
l'amène en fait rager d'accord quand je
vous dirais le mot jardin vous me
donnerez le nom d'un objet qu'on trouve
dans le jardin quand je vous dirais le
mot maison et bien vous me donnerez le
nom d'un objet qu'on trouve dans la
maison
attention attention un chacun son tour
et puis vous aussi vous jouez avec nous
et quand ça sera à casimir de répondre
eh bien vous serrez de répondre plus
vite que lui d'accord on y va on
commence par qui par toi stéphane
approche toi
maison à laufon un bouffon un buffet
très bonnes réponses
nathalie jardin on paye jardin une pelle
pour retourner la terre très bien par
ici
eric jardins jardin un péché qu'est ce
que c'est un péché c'est un arbre tu vas
me joindre et un objet casimir casini
envoyons qu'est ce que je vais lui poser
maison maison une chambre et
réfléchissez un une chambre à soi et
pourquoi c'est par mon garde manger pour
la mettre dans ton regard de une chambre
avec de la crème chantilly
c'est un de mes desserts préférés ben
heureusement qu'ici et chez nos amis il
ya déjà plein de bonnes réponses
allez on continue patrick maison une
télévision
florence méaux encore une table qui n'a
pas répondu
dominic desjardins un arrosoir jardé
encore attend un râteau nathalie jardin
toi viens jouer avec nous dieu je te
dépose de la roue d'accord alors
nathalie jardin un saut très bien eric
maison
les meubles en garde tout à l'heure on a
dit un buffet on a dit une télévision
qu'est ce qu'il ya comme une marina il y
avait laurent là-haut dans laquelle
jacques foule qui voulait jouer alors je
te pose une question non plus décent il
vient avec nous ici un à les sautes de
chercher à les luttes mais ici alors
l'heure en maison un objet qu'on trouve
dans la maison un lit très bien tu te
mets là tu joues avec nous on continue
nathalie une maison enfin dans la maison
un grand drap de lit stéphane genre de
jarden triage un grillage un grillage
pour délimiter le jardin formidable ça
marche très bien
eric mais si vous avez des réponses
données les données lève et vous
cherchez aussi un cheveu
suso vous avez une bonne réponse un
tuyau pour arroser très bien formidable
jardin allez tout le monde répond la une
une cage pour mettre le chien c'est ça
english c'est pas gentil de maître le
chien dans une cage honorer les cheveux
longs et les caches pour les oiseaux
mais les ados tu sais ils sont beaucoup
mieux sans cage casimir manoir jardins
jardin
faites bien attention et s'ils répondent
avant quasi rire - un gong
oui un gong qui fait bang bang un conte
qui fait boum boum et mais qu'est ce que
tu vas en faire mais dans ce jardin
c'est pour prévenir les oiseaux que le
déjeuner servi
je crois plutôt qu'il va les effrayer
les oiseaux
vous êtes toujours là parfait nathalie
desjardins un toboggan comme dans le
jardin de l'île aux enfants mais ça très
bien stéphane de maison un objet de la
maison une table basse et rabie el mahdi
dont casimir je crois que ça va comme ça
hein tu va reconnaître tous les objets
de ta maison et tous les objets de ton
jardin oui ça va mais mais tu sais
jamais devenir un petit peu plus tôt ce
que comme ça j'aurais su où l'on mettait
le râteau et l'aspirateur
pourquoi pas parce que ma tante ursule a
déchiré tous m'ont beaucoup plu râteau
et mon opérateur aspirer tout les
pétales des fleurs du jardin avec
l'aspirateur loulou pauvre casimir